Given the well-documented benefits of breastfeeding
to the long- and short- term health of children,
the American Academy of Pediatrics (AAP) recommends
exclusively breastfeeding infants for at least
the first six months, and continuing to nurse,
along with giving supplemental foods, throughout
the first year of life.
In fact, if one so chooses, babies can get
everything they need nutritionally from the
mother’s milk up until about a year old,
at which point their diet must be supplemented
with solid foods.
However, many women who have had breast implants
fear that they may not be able to breastfeed
their children, assuming that their implants
will impair their ability to nurse, or at
least do so effectively; luckily, this is
mostly a myth, and, in fact, most women with
implants who wish to do so are able to successfully
breastfeed their babies.
The primary determinant in whether or not
a woman with implants will be able to successfully
nurse is not whether the device consists of
silicone or saline, but where and how it was
placed.
Specifically, according to pediatrician and
author of Great Expectations: The Essential
Guide to Breastfeeding, Dr. Marianne Neifert,
nipple incisions should be avoided, as “all
the milk ducts that drain the different lobes
. . . convene there;” rather, they recommend
making an inframammary incision (under the
breast crease) or implanting the device under
the chest wall muscle to maximize the probability
that one would be able to later successfully
breastfeed.
Pressure can also potentially be an issue.
Essentially, the less pressure an implant
puts on the mammary gland, the better.
As Dr. Miriam Labbok of the Carolina Global
Breastfeeding Institute notes, “The mammary
gland, like any other gland, performs normally
when it has blood… and space to grow.
But when you put pressure on any gland in
the body, you risk it malfunctioning and compromising
lactation.”
Many women are also concerned that somehow
an implant may leak or otherwise contaminate
the baby’s milk, but in truth the risks
of leakage with modern implants (in the past
decade or two) is negligible.
Moreover, contrary to popular belief, women
with implants who breastfeed are no more likely
to experience post-pregnancy sagging than
those without.
In fact, for both it isn’t the breastfeeding
that causes the droop, it’s the swelling
of the breasts caused by the hormones that
enlarged them during pregnancy, and the subsequent
reduction in breast size when they are absent.
So, in the end, while there is some chance
that getting breast implants will result in
an inability to breastfeed a baby, for the
vast majority who choose to have this surgery
(nearly a third of a million women in the
U.S. per year), they’ll have no (extra)
trouble with breastfeeding when the time comes.
The word “booby,” in English, first popped
up in the sense of “fool” or “dummy”
around the late sixteenth century and was
within decades applied to birds of the Sula
genus.
These birds have very large feet that make
them look clumsy and foolish when they walk
or run, instead of fly.
In addition, they would often land on ships
and were exceptionally easy to catch, making
them popular fair for sailors, who began calling
these birds “boobies” for their perceived
stupidity.
All that said, this etymology is not
thought to be where the “boobs” moniker
for breasts came from.
More on this
in an upcoming article.